أنا أول امرأة شاذة
تنافس في مسابقة ملكة جمال الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، وكان
قرارًا اتخذته نوعًا من
عمليتي للشفاء وتعلم أن أحب نفسي
وأقبل نفسي ، سأكون صريحًا ، لقد
تم تشخيصي بالاضطراب ثنائي القطب
نوعًا ما  قبل بضع سنوات
وكنت مثل لا ، ليس لدي ذلك
لأنه بدا مخيفًا حقًا كنت
خائفًا ولم أرغب في قبول
أن هذا كان
شيئًا سأعيشه مع بقية
لن تكون مجنونًا في حياتي إذا كنت
تعاني من مشكلة في الصحة العقلية ، فأنت تعلم أنها
مجرد مشكلة صحية مثل أي شيء آخر
إذا تلقيت علاجًا ،
فستتحسن هذا العار وأن الشك الذاتي
في تشخيصي هو جزء من سبب إصابتي.  عشت
في حالة إنكار ولم أقبلها تمامًا
وأعاقتني عن الحصول على المساعدة
وانتهى الأمر بأخذي في مسار أكثر
إيلامًا مما كان ضروريًا ، إنها أكبر لعبة لي من
خلال كل شيء مع
الوسائط والمباهج هو حقًا
لإنقاذ الناس  السنوات الإضافية التي قضيتها في
عدم الحصول عليه  ليرة لبنانية عندما كان من الممكن حقًا أن
يكون طريقًا أقصر بكثير
للشفاء ، ولهذا السبب أنا صريح جدًا
بشأن كل من الاضطراب ثنائي القطب وحياتي
الجنسية أشعر أنه إذا كان هناك المزيد من
الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم يتخذون هذه
المبادرة ليكونوا قادة في هذا المجال
إذًا لن يضطر الكثير من الناس إلى
المعاناة أو المعاناة طالما كنت أفعل
[موسيقى]